[Music]
good morning and welcome to safety Ridge
on Sunday let's be honest Forrest
Johnson was never someone who was going
to leave quietly but in the last 36
hours the former prime minister has been
spray gunning well just about everyone
the Privileges committee a kangaroo
court that launched a Witch Hunt into
partygate conservative MPS don't these
people realize that only in Parliament
because of me he said and above all
dishonorable Rishi sunak so where does
it all leave us is this the start of the
campaign of rebellion from Boris
Johnson's allies to undermine the prime
minister or whisper it could the PM
actually emerge in a stronger position
now the self-styled chief thorn in the
side is leaving Parliament we'll try and
find out on the show today with our
guests in just a moment often sent out
on the defense when the government's
having a tough time energy security and
Net Zero secretary Branch apps we'll be
joined live by someone who knows Boris
Johnson better than most his former
Downing Street director of
communications guitar Hari on the
program this morning and for labor we'll
talk to the shadow Chief secretary to
the treasury that is Pat McFadden plus
with three by-elections coming and of
course a much bigger election across the
country possibly a year away we'll try
and work out what it all means with the
polling expert and chief executive of
ipsos Mori Ben Page
the state of the NHS is one of the PM's
biggest headaches and frankly a big
worry for all of us with more doctor
strikes coming next week we'll talk to
the chair of the BMA Junior doctors
committee Rob lawrenson and a topic that
isn't talked about enough the menopause
we'll try and put that right today with
the labor MP and campaigner Carolyn
Harris
[Music]
good morning well an absolutely packed
show on an extraordinary weekend of
politics lots to get our teeth stuck
into so we can start this morning with
the government a little earlier I spoke
to the energy security and net serious
secretary Grant chaps
have you noticed that on weeks in
Westminster where it seems everything
has been set on fire you were the one
sitting in the seat on Sunday are you
number 10's human fire blanket I'm sure
it's entirely coincidental I mean I I
come on your program from time to time
that was on very recently and I don't
recall uh anything specific but uh I'm
always pleased to come on your program I
mean I'm just thinking you know the
Dominic Cummings Story the more the week
after the local election results the
week after Boris Johnson dramatically
quitting Parliament and this is a grant
chat's week I mean things are exactly
I'm always pleased when you invite me on
I'm very happy to discuss the issues of
the day so it's it's good to be here so
I guess the human fire blanket today
will tell us that everything is fine in
the conservative party and what's
happened with Boris Johnson's just a
distraction well look I I think people
around the country uh you inside and
outside the party will recognize that
Boris was uh is somebody with you know
many qualities but we are now in a world
where there are different challenges um
to face and we've got new management
in number 10 getting on with the job and
getting on with the priorities of this
country like you know growing the
economy and and stopping the small boats
where we've seen some success so I think
the world has sort of moved on from what
was quite a dramatic period under brexit
and of course under the you know the the
issues related to the to covid and the
vaccine and the rest of it so do you
think it was moved on from Boris Johnson
okay I mean just factually speaking
Boris Johnson's no longer prime minister
and you know as I said I think people
are appreciate I I like Boris Johnson I
worked under his administration he had
successes many successes to his name in
including breaking the brexit impasse
and including getting this country
vaccinated first but there was also
always a lot of drama that came with all
of that uh the world has moved on not
least because of person's invasion of
Ukraine the high
levels of inflation that created and so
things like fighting inflation and uh
growing the economy and the things that
Rishi sunac is focused on now and as you
said having some success with with
things like stop you know reducing the
number of small boats we've seen them
down 20 this year I think the world has
moved on in that regard you say that
there was always a lot of drama around
Boris Johnson which is a bit of an
understatement really
um are you hoping that now some of that
drama the soap opera if you like will
come to an end well my my sense is that
what people want are basically the five
priorities that this prime minister
Rishi said I was wondering how tall it
would be to yeah
so someone on Twitter said please don't
let him say what the five priorities are
unless you specifically ask what are the
facts I won't give you a list but I will
say that things like stopping the small
boats as I mentioned are really
important and we're having success in
that right
yes I mean are are we moving on has the
world moved yes yeah of course of course
it's moved on and these are things are
of our facts aren't they the Boris
Johnson has now said that he is stepping
down uh as an MP so yes factually things
have moved on and now according to the
newspapers this morning this all stems
partly from a meeting nine days ago
between Rishi sunak and Boris Johnson
and Boris Johnson's allies are accusing
Rishi sunak of effectively going back on
his word and not allowing through the
people that Boris Johnson or all the
people that Boris Johnson wanted to
nominate for peerages well look I don't
want to comment on individual meetings
that I wasn't
um I I can't confirm that either way
what I can say for certain is that
resisting act has not changed altered uh
the list in any way in fact there is a
House of Commons appointments uh
commission or holak as it's called which
looks at all nominations there's a very
very uh long-tested uh protocol in place
where former Prime Ministers put people
up for the house of laws I think I'm
right and saying that Gordon Brown Put
up about 50 people in his nominations
list and the Prime Minister who comes in
usually passes on in this particular
case because number 10 is actually
published the uh the the details you can
see that uh Rishi did not change that
list at all the House of Commons
commission will have made all of those
decisions and the Prime Minister has not
intervened in any way do you think Boris
Johnson didn't understand the details
then is that what you're saying
occasionally Boris wouldn't be all over
the detail I don't know whether that's
what happened in this particular case
okay
of course the real trigger was Boris
Johnson receiving the findings of the
Privileges committee report into whether
he misled Parliament over party gate he
says it's a kangaroo court he says it's
a Witch Hunt do you agree with him well
look uh Boris has seen this report I
haven't other MPS haven't seen the
report yet so I have to get receipts of
of that there's a formal process that's
put in place I don't want to undermine
Parliament itself which is what coming
to that conclusion would do so so you
say come into the conclusion that the
privilege privileges committee is a
kangaroo Carl or a Witch Hunt would be
undermining Parliament well Parliament
itself sets up these committees and they
are uh set up in in proportion to the
current uh make up a parliament um which
is I don't know 54 conservative so
there'll be conservatives on that
committee so you're saying that Boris
Johnson's underminling I I I'm simply
saying I haven't seen that report uh
only Boris has seen it so I don't know
quite what he's getting at when he says
that I haven't seen the report I haven't
seen the evidence they presented what I
do believe is it's very important to let
committees get on with their uh work uh
you know I think the point of a member
being sent details in advance as has
happened with Boris is that it gives
somebody the opportunity to comment on
it and say no this is an accuracy here
or what have you and and challenge
elements before it's published uh as a I
haven't seen it so you're asking to
comment on something I haven't seen do I
think that the process uh is is proper
well that's the decision for Parliament
not the government but Parliament and
MPS to decide themselves and this is the
process that MPS have collectively
decided should be in place in situations
like this so Boris Johnson in his
resignation letter says there is a Witch
Hunt underway to take revenge for brexit
and ultimately to reverse the 2016
referendum result so I definitely don't
feel that way I think I'm somebody who
thinks that I'm actually having to vote
for breasts as it happens but I actually
do think it's working in favor for this
country I'm seeing how we are now able
to move much faster uh in getting on
with the job in lots of different ways
uh changing rules which enable us to
bring in more Innovative Tech and uh
actually use the advantages of being
outside of the EU but working very
closely with our neighbors and friends
so I think far from wanting to undo it I
think we're in a phase now of using the
many benefits of having that extra
flexibility so no I don't think that's
the case I don't want to get into a row
about whether or not brexit is working
or not but just to say you're not the
only person uh you're not all of your
colleagues agree with you on the
treatment of Ross Johnson and the
committee report I just want to have a
look at Jake Berry MP who tweeted to say
this
you voted for brexit he's talking about
the reader if you like you voted for
brexit the establishment blocked it you
voted for Boris Johnson The
Establishment forced him out who is in
charge here the voters or the blob do
you agree with Jake Barry no
um you know actually in the end Boris
was perfectly entitled to remain as a MP
he has decided to stand down in a couple
of my uh other colleagues all the
promotions that I've worked with and uh
and and Boris in particular I I liked
working with him uh as prime minister
but as I said right at the the beginning
of this the world has moved on he is the
one who's removed himself from uh the
current sort of political um scene
standing down as a member of Parliament
and we've got excellent leadership in
place in number 10 I guess what Jake
Berry and other supporters are saying is
that they feel it's undemocratic Boris
Johnson won an election Landslide unlike
Rishi Cena by the way uh who you know
hasn't got his mandate from the
electorate in the same way that Boris
Johnson did he was elected by the voters
in his constituency of Uxbridge and
South ruislip and once again they feel
it's MPS it's his own side almost
forcing him out not the public well as I
say only only Boris Johnson himself can
make the decision as he's done to stand
down from Parliament no one well they've
said the Privileges committee is going
to give if is if we understand it
correctly is going to give him a
suspension that is so long he'd have to
face a by-election well as I say uh he's
had the benefit of seeing that committed
report it's a parliamentary committee
it's not something the government is is
doing and so these are you know these
things are Boris Johnson's decision to
do I think actually you know when you
look at I'm not going to list the five
priorities but if you look at the
priorities of this country getting on
with the the job after you know covid
and a war in Ukraine and very high
inflation those are the things that
people are really concerned about and
those are the things that this prime
minister is focused on Richardson well
if he's not doing a very good job is it
if you look at the polls and in the
resignation that's the one thing that
Boris Johnson does unarguably get right
is that when he left office last year
the government was a handful of points
behind on the polls that gaps widened
just a few years after winning the
biggest majority in almost half a
century that majority is now clearly at
risk you cannot argue with that that's
right and so if you basically say that
Rishi sunak is getting on with the job
because in tune with what what people
want what they're saying is we don't
really like what's what yeah that's I
was gonna say that's not quite the full
story is it because if you recall last
summer there were rather a lot of
different changes including a another
prime minister as well and that's when
we were a very very long behind way
behind and polls over 30 points behind
we know from the local elections where I
think we were nine points behind there's
actually a lot closer come on the local
elections were were totally okay well
even if you want to use the same base as
say the polling was 30 points behind and
it's now say 15 points behind in other
words uh Rishi tsuna focusing on
people's actual priorities stopping the
small boats and
and the rest of it means that actually
we are seeing that pole got narrow but
let's just be absolutely key you know
and I know you won't want me to talk
about the other option which is a kirst
armor government but the reality is we
have very low unemployment in this
country near record levels of high
employment all of that's happened under
a conservative government and there's
never been a labor government that
hasn't left unemployment higher in
history and so that's the real challenge
here is to make sure we can preserve the
things which are working like a lot of
jobs available in our economy do you
think Boris Johnson will come back I
have the one thing I know about Boris
Johnson is never predict what Boris
Johnson will will do next I have no idea
uh what will happen in regards to that
would you like to know I I'm sure he's
got many other things he wants to get on
to do it doesn't sound like you're
really gay
he spent a huge amount he's spending a
lot of time around the world uh uh
making a lot of uh so that's what you
want to do leave the country not just
Parliament I I said hey you don't you
won't find me saying bad things about
Boris I enjoyed working with Boris I
thought he was uh I thought he was the
right man for that time particularly to
break that brexit empath which he
successfully did I thought he was very
good leading in leadership of the world
in Ukraine after the invasion and other
things but a lot of drama came with it
we've got a series of very important
things that we're focused on now like
reducing inflation and growing the
economy and those things are starting to
work we see Germany in recession the
Eurozone in recession this country
actually escaping recession uh because
we've got the right measures in place
under Rishi well and I think lots of
people would say that if you look at the
economic situation if you really want to
go down the argument about what economic
situation we're in with a you know
mortgage sort of Time Bomb inflation
much stickier than expected I'm not sure
that that's really the strong point that
you'd be fighting zero growth well I
just say first of all it's not zero
growth we just had the biggest upgrade
uh of any uh country uh in I think the
iron flatlining Grace within the UK and
no uh they're actually predicting growth
this year
I think 0.5 uh percent point seven
percent uh is is possible depending on
which uh uh economists you follow uh
remember that six months ago they said
that we would be in recession remember
that Germany is in recession that the
Eurozone is in recession and I know
there's a kind of desire to sort of
constantly say somehow that we're doing
worse than everyone else our economy
grew faster
than the year before I'm just I won't be
right up there this year I'm not I'm not
saying that what I'm saying is we have
0.5 predicted inflation running at
around ten percent this is a fall in
real incomes and it's really really
really difficult for people right now
and I don't think we should necessarily
be you know rubbing our hands look I'm
not in any way shape or form saying that
I am saying that things like
unemployment are great achievements but
that's why the first on the list of five
that you won't allow me to mention is to
get to halve inflation and it is why uh
you know inflations like attacks on
people it is why we're working so hard
on that uh it's why Jeremy Hunt the
chancellor and Rishi are so focused on
that as their first priority it costs
everybody when inflation's high and
that's why we're we're pressing down on
it you've got a couple of by-elections
coming up now because not only is Boris
Johnson standing down but two of his key
allies are as well could be pretty
tricky particularly in Uxbridge when
you're a performer party chair how
confident are you feeling about that
yeah I look at it we will fight for
every vote as a every former and current
party chair will tell you
um and we'll be presenting our message
and what we'll be saying to people in
Oxford or elsewhere is look since the
only other viable option to run the
country is
is castama or a combination of him and
the lib Dems and the s p goodness knows
what else know what you're voting for
which in you know just in the last week
we've seen labor either pledging or not
pledging 28 billion pounds of tax and
spend uh on a program which is in a in a
mess uh and uh and and doing whatever
just stop oil tell them should be their
policy on energy my area which would
cost families a fortune that 28 billion
uh pledge is about a thousand pounds per
family they want to put our energy
policy in the hands of people they would
argue I mean look I'm going to talk
about the 28 billion policy with labor
as you'd expect but they would argue
look this is actually about energy
security something that people really
really care about and it's also about
creating half a minute and it's
extraordinary that their actual policy
would create energy insecurity make us
reliant on tyrants like Putin by
importing gas and oil uh that we need
still as we make that transition to Net
Zero we end up importing it abroad and
we're still we double the carbon it's a
completely illiterate policy that
they've got from their their from their
just stop oil friends let's let's talk
we'll talk about that policy with labor
um I just want to talk to you about one
of your uh policies as well if I may
because you know there has been some
criticism by Boris Johnson for vicious
you know not following through with some
of his plans it feels like one of them
could be the plan for Great British
Railways I mean that's your baby you're
trying to fix the way that Railways are
fragmented if you like and the times
have reported that it won't be in The
King's Speech it's being watered down no
legislative powers to sign off contracts
to set fares are you a bit worried so
just be absolutely clear Great British
Railways is happening as I understand
I'm no longer transport secretary you
have the transport secretary talk about
it but uh it is happening it is a
different way to arrange the railways an
awful lot of what's required doesn't
require a major Act of parliament
immediately to get that going so the
body itself is being established I think
it's going to be based in Derby the
competition uh was was was announced for
the headquarters a lot of what's
required can be done by repurposing the
kind of vehicles that are already there
so I think the question of at what point
you have to pass the so-called primary
legislation through Parliament is
separate to getting on with the job of
reorganizing the way the railways run
and that's continuing okay and the thing
that you want to talk to uh about today
is more funding to support people with
health issues to stay at work what I do
look we we have uh as I say a great
track record on employment but we're
also aware and particularly post covered
are people who've found it difficult to
stay in the workplace or are dropping
out of the workplace the funding that
we're making available to ensure that
people can stay and work and are
supported to do so we think where people
can be economically active it's better
for them it's better for their health is
better for the economy as well okay and
just finally uh we're going to be
talking to the BMA later on the program
because of course Junior doctors are
striking next week part of a
long-running dispute we'll get their
View later but what's your message to
them so simply this you know first of
all to the whole of the Health Service
and the NHS uh you know we really want
to see this service working for people
is why one of the pledges that I won't
mention is to cut the waiting list which
I won't list in detail which is cut the
waiting list
um and one of the things we need to do
as a responsible government is press
down on inflation as well we can't be in
a situation where we end up in the
spiral of pay claims which bust
inflation and end up in a position where
we never get inflation out the system so
it's about coming to a fair settlement
both for the junior doctors and for the
rest of the public service and frankly
people who don't work in the public
service to make sure that we are uh
getting that balance right and that's
what we're trying to do I really hope
that these uh industrial disputes can be
brought to a close so we can all get on
with the things we're we're trying to do
for example we've got rid of the
two-year weights we've got rid of 90 of
the 18-month weights we're making
progress with the NHS recovery
okay we'll put some of those points to
the junior doctors later thank you very
much thank you
uh Grant chaps there the world has moved
on from Boris Johnson according to Grant
Champs well as you can tell inescapably
the main topic of the day is of course
Boris Johnson and one man who knows is
thinking better than most is katihari
who was with him in his City Hall days
when the mayor of London and more
recently his communications director in
shall we say tumultuous times down the
street he joins us now I've been really
looking forward to interviewing on the
show frankly because we see an awful lot
of anonymized quotes from allies of
Boris Johnson with no idea who they are
you are an ally or Boris Johnson and
you're close to him if anyone can help
us get inside his head as you so what do
you think is going on inside Boris
Johnson's head right now I think what
he's done is take charge this weekend of
a situation that was out of his control
and drifting you know inevitably towards
a very very unhappy and undignified sort
of conclusion and so if you like he's
gone jumping in you know waving Union
Jacks if you like
um rather than be drag kicking and
screaming out of Parliament and though I
won't join those who open exercise the
process and all that I do understand why
he feels uh understandably aggrieved by
the process that has not only taken him
out of office stopped him being prime
minister but now hounded him out of
politics because as you rightly said he
is a man who uh defied political gravity
and only a couple of years or a few
years ago won the biggest majority for
40 years and so I think those people who
voted conservative most of them having
never contemplated voting conservative
before it was very much a personalized
Boris branded pitch at the last election
will feel aggrieved that the man who
they wanted as prime minister is now not
even in Parliament not to mention in
number 10. I want to get into some of
those processes a bit later in the
interview
um he dramatically quit his seat for now
do you think it's going to be back uh
you never know he keeps you know he
deliberately leaves us guessing doesn't
he hasta la vista baby or you know more
classical references it's very important
it's virtually impossible to to write
him off but I don't think this is part
of an elaborate plot to sort of
destabilize and topple Rishi sunak I
think uh Boris Johnson feels that there
is an opportunity for him now to go off
and you know lick his wounds but also
sees New Opportunities is very talented
a person who's in demand around the
world as a speaker he's writing his
Memoirs he's a great writer so there's a
little time for him to be out of The
Fray but will he come back one day who
knows in other words then is it because
he thinks he would lose the by-elections
in a scene is that why it's a little bit
none of us wants to interview for our
own job and we certainly want to be
interviewed for our own job under the
most appalling circumstances where a
committee LED frankly by a woman who
I've got a lot of respect for but among
the many jobs that Harry Thomas done in
the past has been leading the labor
party she's Deputy leader of labor party
for a long time can you imagine any
labor supporter being happy if someone
like William Hague shall we say uh had
had the fate of Kia starmer in his hands
when he was caught drinking beer and
having curry with friends A Long Way
from Home in the middle of lockdown I
don't think people would be comfortable
with that process nor should they be and
so I understand why Boris feels
aggrieved and I understand why a lot of
people watching this will think whoa so
committee led by the former labor leader
can actually Hound Boris out of office
when the police actually found him
guilty of one minor misdemeanor that was
worth a 50 Quid fine at the same time
it's not just Harriet Hammond though is
it it's a cross-party group there's a
majority of conservatives on that
committee yeah that doesn't you know
that's often a worse than having your
political opponents there as people from
the same parties as you know better than
most um so if there's so many cross
currents in a party and you know so I
don't think that having a conservative
majority means that you're you know
well-being is is safeguarded it also had
to be voted through by the house as well
so he's assuming that the draw a lot of
considerable number of people on his own
side went back into you I think he's
just thinking do you know the true test
in a democracy is whether the people
vote for you 14 million people voted him
for him pretty much at the last election
they voted for MPS but it was very much
he could have gone to vote tonight well
he could have done but again you know in
the situation when you are standing in a
by-election under these sort of
circumstances where people are reading
that you've lied to Parliament because
the former leader of the labor party has
decided that you did it's not ideal to
have to reapply for your own job so I
don't blame him at all for just saying
you know Buster because he enough is
enough I'm out of here have you spoken
to him I speak to him from time to time
um uh and uh you know I think he is
enjoying you know life beyond politics
um his personal life is in a great place
he's going to be a father again uh very
very soon and he's traveling the world
so earning quite a bit of money as well
yeah which which he hasn't done for most
of his life
um now we talked a bit about the party
gate inquiry the other strand of this is
the Honors that Boris Johnson put
forward and this meeting uh between
Rishi sunak and Boris Johnson
um we heard from Grant chap saying that
actually where she seen that didn't get
involved in the process it was all
completely kosher above board perhaps
Boris Johnson didn't understand the
details of what was happening uh like
that I wasn't in the room so I don't
know what happened at that meeting
um but uh as I understand it there's
been a lot of touring and throwing about
this list uh and I think the relevant
authorities were not happy with the
scale of it and some of the nominations
in the originally uh what is nice about
the final list is I look at colleagues
who I've known for a long long time
people who put in an enormous shift at
City Hall 80 years of the mayoralty
people whose names you probably don't
know certainly most of the audience
don't but Boris has in this list taking
care of a whole load of you know decent
men and women who put in an enormous
shift without Fame nor fortune and these
people important to keep the show on the
roads and if we think that politics
matters then we've got to be a little
bit less contemptuous of people engage
in politics whether they're in the back
room or front of house you're on the
list
yes but the real honor for me was having
a chance to serve in number 10 last year
it was brutal it was pretty rough
um but it was also very important and
Boris led the world in helping zelenski
stand up to Putin in the Ukraine he
helped lead Britain out of covid and
unfortunately we crashed into a cost of
living crisis and he got wrestling with
that he was wrestling with energy policy
there was all this stuff going on and
yet if you turned on the television with
some exceptions most of the time all you
would hear was this constant myopic diet
to partygate this party gave that party
gave this party gave that and so he
never had a fair hearing I don't think
uh last year no some of that was partly
of his own making but you know some
things happened before I got there but I
think there was an awful lot to be proud
of that happened last year and a lot for
people like Boris to feel aggrieved of
that it was basically taken away from
him I mean you were there in an absolute
roller coaster at the time weren't you
yeah what do you think was the maddest
day the day the most difficult day or
funny enough the moments where I thought
it was lost was when the party when when
those who managed the conservative party
told Boris that they did not want to
oppose this labor motion to set up the
Privileges committee because for me we
had already had a police investigation
we had the sugray inquiry
um there'd been a vote of confidence in
Boris which you won two-thirds of the
party backed him so I thought surely at
this point we can just move on and focus
on what we need to do to sort of
to address the concerns of Voters rather
than the obsessions of the Twitter Arty
and you know I do just want to come back
because because you know when we talk
about party I get a lot of people saying
this is this is a huge part of our life
we couldn't see loved ones we lost
people without saying goodbye to them
and that goes for him Boris Johnson he
lost his mother I lost my sister it's
this narrative that somehow out there
people were suffering and in here they
were partying hey they were not partying
you know working hard and you've got a
50 Quid fine no that would be the end of
the matter for a civilian but in Boris
Johnson's case something that the police
with all their powers investigation all
the due process and the thoroughness
with which they check things out found
him guilty of something worthy of 50
Quid fine since then he's been hounded
out of office as prime minister and now
handed out of parliament I mean in terms
of proportionality if he was a civilian
um that would be that would be unfair
does he blame Rishi sunak
I don't think he blames uh Rishi sunak
um you know for for much of this he was
very disappointed at the time that Rishi
sunai did not even tell him face to face
that he was resigning I mean because the
other person resigned on that day
Saturday did he was you know man enough
if you like to go and see Boris and tell
him to his face I'm resigning I can't
stand this anymore we discovered on the
Telly that that Rishi had gone so but in
the end the whole party or a big chunk
of the party turned against for us and
that's the reality he's had to wrestle
with but the reason that they did that
is because they couldn't see any other
way of stopping this miserable Purgatory
of turning on the Telly every day and
all they would see is stuff about
partygate and so they decided in the end
whether it's fear or not that they just
couldn't carry on with that the
relationship between Rishi Cena and
Boris Johnson is obviously pretty toxic
right well I sat down with him every
morning you know about 8 15 for seven
months of my life felt like a lot longer
and um
and actually I was surprised when I got
there because I had not met uh Rishi
sunai but the personal chemistry was
very very warm the two of them got on
really well that was at one time it's
now changed well yeah but what I'm
saying is I don't think it's the
personal thing I think it's you know
Rishi is now doing the job that Boris
used to do now none of us feel very good
about people doing that if it's been
forced upon us
um I always saw Rishi as the natural
successor but many many years down the
line and actually he cut to the chase
um though actually he wasn't the
beneficiary of the toppling of Boris it
was but he's eventually ended up uh in
power and I wish him well because at
this point in time it is the only game
in town and any conservative who thinks
that prolonging the agony prolonging the
pain prolonging the division dancing on
boris's political grave or undermining
Rishi sunak is mad do you think there's
any way of patching up these warring
sides yes because I think in the end
what we now have is very different we
don't have the Charisma we don't have
the connection we don't have that Unique
Kind of uh
charismatic you're saying oh clearly not
but he's he's hard-working he's clean
living He beavers away and he does
details so the two of them for me were a
perfect tag team you know they
complemented each other's skills very
very well now going into a general
election with Richie will have certain
disadvantages versus Boris particularly
when you're appealing to working class
blokes across you know swathes of uh the
north of England and the north my native
country Wales
because because they'll miss that sort
of they'll miss that umphrine panas and
and alpha male them I guess but on the
other hand when you're looking at the
choice between clear starma and Rishi
sunak you sort of think well actually if
what we need is somebody is capable and
competent and hard working then
why change you've got Rishi in there
he's young he's bright he's well
qualified particularly to handle the
economy
um and and he's tea total okay
um well then yeah that is one thing that
he's differs to uh voice Johnson again
so now just finally you've been we've
been talking about the interview there
you've been in the eye of the storm as
director of communications
how are you finding life on the outside
um I've just been reliving some of my
number 10 days because I've done this
podcast unprecedented and I urge I'm
sure you've listened to it but uh I urge
anyone wants to understand what really
happened to have a listen because last
year was portrayed in sort of polarized
Extreme Ways and there was a lot more
subtlety to it there was a lot more
texture to it and so I've been reliving
that but otherwise you know I'm doing a
lot more shifts with the rnli where I'm
a volunteer on the Thames uh hopefully
progressing my training there because I
I skimped on my shifts last year and uh
and a lot more time for you know family
and friends always good thank you very
much indeed for coming on the program
today thank you good to talk
uh well we have heard there from both
Ally and Grant shops probably not
described as a forest La after that
interview and as you would expect the
labor party hasn't held back either the
deputy leader Angela Rayner said that
Boris Johnson is an absolute disgrace
and a coward for the party will no doubt
enjoy the focus being back on the
conservatives tearing lumps out of each
other meanwhile there was some
discomfort of the rain this week as
Rachel Ryu seemed to roll back on the
party's much publicized 28 billion pound
a year Green Spending plans well the
Cello's Chief Secretary of the Treasury
pattern joins us now good to have you on
the program good morning so Kristan was
calling for an election why is now the
time
because I don't think there's any cure
for this chaos under the current
government what the last few days have
shown us is not only lots of things we
already knew about Boris Johnson and how
we blame everybody else for his downfall
but the way that he attacked which is
anakiness he first of all used and
played Richardson act to get approval
for this uh honors list that he wanted
before he went but then in that
resignation statement that he made on
Friday he has attacked a number of
policies around not having a trade deal
with the United States
post-brexit policies uh the tax position
but he's also attacked which is your
next future strategy he said that if
Rishi sunak and Jeremy Hunt bring in
pre-election tax cuts it'll be seen
through as a gimmick so he's not only
attacking Rishi present he's attacking
Rishi future too and the conclusion is
this is not over this is going to
continue it's not that surprise is it
where you know one of your predecessors
attacks you I mean look at the
relationship between kirst armor and
Jeremy corbyn this is nothing new is it
they're the party of government and if
this goes on the chaos will continue
you've got Jacobi smog one of Boris
Johnson's principal allies writing in
one of the Sunday newspapers today that
not only should Boris come back but he'd
be a good candidate in a future
leadership election so it's quite clear
this is going to continue in the
conservative party and they cannot fix
it themselves the only way to fix this
is to have a general election and a
change of government otherwise the
country is going to be bedeviled by this
chaos and instability and it's having a
real effect on the governance and the
economy of the country there'll be some
elections uh pretty quickly three
by-elections coming up including of
course in Boston's old seat in Oxbridge
has labor got a real chance
yes I I think we I think we have we're
going to fight all of these by-elections
to win there are no no-go areas for the
labor party and I think that these
violations can be the first step towards
removing the government uh that's the
message that we'll be giving to voters
uh in those constituencies and we're
going to fight all of them hard who are
going to fight all of them to win we
just had from katihari who was talking
about the Privileges committee and
saying that look he understands why
Boris Johnson Fields handed out by a
committee that was led by Harriet Harman
of course the leading figure in the
labor party Forrest Johnson has
described it as a kangaroo court do you
understand why some closer Bros Johnson
feel that what's happened is a bit
undemocratic you know he won a landslide
he was elected in Uxbridge wiser MPS who
are forcing him out this is Trump like
on both sides of the Atlantic uh the
statement that he made apart from the
parts which attack electricity sunite
great left and Center on Friday we're
all about him avoiding responsibility
for his own actions he's got a record of
trying to trash institutions in his own
interests that's what he was doing on
Friday the committee has a conservative
majority he's got a conservative
majority that's really important for
viewers to understand also the
committee's verdict isn't the last word
it then goes to Parliament where the
Tories are sitting on a majority of
around 66 seats at least it was on
Friday before they all started resigning
and even then it just triggers a recall
petition where he could face the voters
the truth is he didn't want to face any
of the verdicts because he can never
accept responsibility for his own
actions and that's true of all these
right-wing populist leaders they're like
baby men whenever anything goes wrong
it's everybody else's fault that was the
characteristics in the statement on
Friday and it just revealed to us that
the Tory party can't resolve this on its
own right we've talked an awful lot
about Boris Johnson let's talk about
some other things shall we uh you've
done some analysis on mortgages which to
be honest is something that I know many
of our viewers they're going to be
really genuinely quite worried about
what have you found we found that
compared to two years ago uh interest
rates have added some seven thousand
Pounds a year to the average uh mortgage
bill and the thing that really boost the
Rockets under the mortgage rates was the
conservative disastrous mini budget uh
last September that's when markets lost
confidence in the UK that's when the
Tories shredded any reputation for
economic stability and responsibility
that they had and people are paying the
price for that every month as their
previous two or five year rates that
they've been on come up it's not just
that though is it like I I accept that
you know what happened in that mini
budget was a pretty disastrous for the
markets but look it's also about other
things isn't it like you know Global
High inflation as well and I guess my
point is rather than looking at the
causes of it what was Labor going to do
about it you've identified the problem
what's your solution well first of all
it's a big part of that that really
boosted solution the solution has to be
Financial stability for the long term uh
that's what we want to ensure uh the
lesson from uh the experience last
September should be that we any future
government has to put Financial
stability first has to make sure that it
matches ambition with responsibility and
that's what will characterize our
approach
um I just wonder the responsibility
argument the financial stability if that
comes into the debate that is going on
around this 28 billion pound a year that
labor wants to spend on green energy now
there's been lots of talk this week
about Labor rowing back from the plan
but as far as I can tell you're not
really rolling back from are you you're
saying that you are going to end up
spending 28 billion a year on green
energy but just not immediately well two
things have changed since we announced
this plan A couple of years ago first of
all the economic situation that we're
talking about we've had 12 interest rate
Rises we've had the experience of that
uh Tory mini budget last year and that
has underlined the need for financial
stability but my point is just doing it
okay you're not doing it year one but
that was never going to happen was that
you're still saying that you are going
to end up spending 28. the second thing
the second thing is really important
it's also changed in the last two years
which is in every conversation that
we've had with uh investors and
businesses we've discovered a real
thirst for private sector investment in
this too and we've also had the
experience of the inflation reduction
act in the United States and that's been
not just about what government does but
about crowding in the private sector
investment so I don't think the right
lens to look at this through is just
what government borrows and invests an
essential part of of that this is it's
also about what you can do in
partnership with a private sector we've
got a big long-term plan for this it's
also a responsible long-term plan and it
can lead the country through a change
that is going to happen it's an awful
lot of money though isn't it 28 billion
every year and there's all going to be
all sorts of departments who are going
to be looking at this saying hang a
minute I need to build more homes I need
to invest in schools and hospitals 28
billion you could knock a billion off
that and say it was a surrounding error
is Ed miliband his policy is he going to
cost you another election
look this is an ambitious policy there
are always trade-offs and choices uh in
government but the announcement that we
made on Friday said one very important
thing to the British public which is
that we will match our Ambitions with
responsibility we will also match them
by crowding in private sector investment
that's the best way to do this to lead
the country through a big change so that
when it comes to the election we're much
in realism with hope and that's the
right approach uh just finally
um there have been some allegations
claims made about MPS in the labor party
and behavior that they have allegedly
been part of most recently labor Shadow
Minister bambo sharolambers suspended
over a complaint I don't want to get
into the details because obviously there
are two sides to every story people
deserve a fair hearing
but it's a labor party really serious
about behavior in Westminster and
rooting anything out that is improper
yes we are
I mean like you I don't want to get into
an individual case but I've worked
around Westminster for a very long time
both as an MP and previously I worked in
number 10. you know I want this to be a
place where both politicians and the
many staff members who who work there
can come into work excited about what
they're doing working in public service
whether they're working for the
governing party or the opposition party
uh and be confident that it's a great
place to work so I'm saddened when I see
these allegations they should all be
properly investigated but let's make
sure that Westminster is a good place to
work and embodies the best of Public
Service okay thank you very much indeed
uh
talking for the labor party you're
watching at Safeway Ridge on Sunday it
is a jam-packed show for you this
morning we've heard of course from the
government we've heard from base kind of
pro and I says guest Pro Boris Pro Rishi
supporters and the take will follow this
program probably a little after 9 30 to
say because they've got an awful lot of
interviews as you get through but before
that we are going to get some analysis
from repel our political correspondent
who is here with us today
well what's your big Takeaway on the big
story of the day the Boris Johnson story
after hearing people talk this morning I
thought what Grant chap said right at
the top of the interview risks actually
inflaming this sort of battle we've been
uh reporting on for the last couple of
days between those close to Boris
Johnson and those close to Rishi soon
have because it was delivered in a sort
of typical affable and amiable way but
it was actually quite biting when you
look at what he said he basically said
at one point that the world has moved on
um and that uh Boris Johnson was the
right man for his time but he was the
one that decided to remove himself from
the current political scene also when
you asked him about you know whether
Boris Johnson was a details man in
relation to the honors story he said
occasionally he could he might not be
across um the detail he talked about the
conservative party being Under New
Management now that was a phrase
kierstama used to try and separate
himself from Jeremy corbyn when he had
just taken over so I think that was
quite quietly cutting and actually from
a senior cabinet minister that suggests
that number 10 are not afraid to stand
their ground on this and try and use
this whole episode to try and kind of
exercise the ghost of Boris Johnson once
and for all and I think if they can do
that actually this could all be working
to their advantage in the longer term
but of course they've got a bumpy period
getting through if you buy-elections to
come before then yeah absolutely right
on the by-elections I think you're right
as well it was if you look at the
language that he was using pretty
cutting I think at one point I was like
do you think I'll come back he's like
well he's got lots of things to do
around the world it's like you couldn't
get any further away
um Rob thank you very much for your
analysis it's always good to have you on
the program Rob pal uh there well Rob
was just talking about those bumpy
by-elections coming down the line for
the conservatives they're still of
course a very long way behind labor in
the polls uh most suggest I think here
starmer would make it into Downing
Street at the next election at least as
the biggest party if not with a majority
so a good time to have a closer look at
what the polls say in particular in
those three seats up for grabs we're
joined out by the ipsos Maurice CEO Ben
Page great to have you on the program
nice to see you now the first question
I'm really interested to get your view
on is how popular is Boris Johnson uh
not very I think let's let's just be
frank two out of three people think he's
lied and misled Parliament and when we
asked people which were the which prime
minister they thinks did a good job or a
bad job Boris Johnson tops the bad job
list by some margin he does have a you
know a minority of people who are still
fans but it's much smaller than some of
his back benchers think quite frankly I
mean this is what you were just
mentioning about did he lie did the
sports Johnson Mrs Lee Parliament 65
saying he did yeah he's a big number it
is exactly and but remember I think
Boris Johnson did always get a free pass
in many ways even before he became prime
minister
um many more people thought he was
untrustworthy and didn't tell the truth
than did and it just got worse from
there so
um some of that sort of prized him and I
think that's the key Point Boris Johnson
does strange things and accuses
parliament of Kangaroo Court Etc
for a lot of people they're just going
to say next
are you about Boris Johnson's popularity
versus Russia I think we can have a
quick look at some of the research that
you've done on this so this is Boris
Johnson investors Richie sunac who do
you think would be a better pm and the
kind of dark blue line there is
effectively the student numbers so 28
all voters say he would be a better PM
compared to 17 say Boris Johnson
including actually the 2019 concept of
Voters yes so even among conservative
voters the dwindling band of
conservative voters many more say that
sunac would be a better prime minister
than Johnson so I think in many ways you
would say on that on the basis of that
his um his time is over in politics for
the moment that's really interesting uh
to hear because you know Boris Johnson's
resignation letter when I left office
last year the government was only a few
handful of points behind the polls he
also points the fact he won the biggest
majority in almost half a century the
majority was clearly at risk what do you
say to that argument
um he was already very unpopular by the
time he he left office and the Trump you
know the likelihood of him winning as
prime minister is less likely than sunak
to be quite honest so
um you know yes he's got a lot he has
some supporters but really his you know
his time all political careers end in
failure and you start as maybe popular
and end up unpopular but uh his
trajectory is pretty dramatic why would
anyone go into politics that's one
reason I never have I'm me I am also
very interested to know what is going on
with these violations that coming out
because we've got three eye-elections
coming up it feels to me like the most
interesting is probably that one Boris
Johnson's content absolutely Oxbridge
and Southwest so the 7 000 majority this
if if if
um starmer is going to win a general
election convincingly this ought to be
in many ways a breeze for labor and they
have held the seat as recently as the
1960s or the you know in that particular
part but that's that's really is going
to be an acid test if that if they
Breeze through that then all the polls
showing on average 16-point lead for
labor people will bake it in if they
don't or it's only a very narrow win I
think there will be a lot more
uncertainty and then we come on to the
lib Dems chances in the dean dory's seat
in mid beds where again they might do it
it's a huge majority 24 and a half
thousand but they've done things like
that before in Amazon term it does
require labor in that seat to really
stand down because if you look at the
amishim vote by election I think labor
got fewer votes than in virtually any
election they had about only 600 people
in amersham actually voted labor wow in
that by-election so it requires a fair
amount of tactical voting and I think
the challenge in this situation as we
approach as we're now much closer to a
general election is is labor going to
really stand aside to give the um you
know to give everybody a chance that's
really interesting because Ed Davey's
gone to the seeds and to be honest I had
a look at this this is the tablet here
this is what happened last time yeah you
can see the lib Dems in third place I
lived there and I was like
that's optimistic isn't it from a lib
Dem so they you know but maybe you're
right maybe there was a bit of tactical
voting yeah things could change that
that's probably their best Prospect and
then we go on to of course
where again you know a big swing needed
it's it's actually gone more and more
Tori over the last few elections with
Nigel Adams uh again you'd want to see
some really good progress there by labor
maybe the liberal Democrats decide not
to bother too much there and uh leave it
to labor to have a go who knows but
again you'll be looking for signs
everybody will be looking for signs that
labor really is delivering on the ground
uh I guess the conservatives just hope
to get this all over and done with as
quickly as possible fascinating is there
a landing Zone finally for Russia Scenic
do you think at the general elections
well I mean the conservatives are
currently on 28 percentage points one of
the rules of British politics is that
you can put a parrot on a stick and it
should if it's standing for labor or the
conservatives get around 29 30 percent
the vote Jeremy corbyn I thought was
going to break this rule in 2017 because
he started off the general election
campaign on 26 percent but lo and behold
he was steamed past that number so
nobody you know this will be unknown
territory if if this happens it will
also be unknown territory though for
Kirsten if he becomes prime minister
because his personal ratings are some of
the lowest for any leader of the
opposition who looks like they're going
to win a general election he's not
particularly popular as an individual
but maybe now we're fed up with
excitement and Charisma and we just want
something else it's absolutely
fascinating you know it's been really
interesting talk I feel like I've
learned an awful lot from this
conversation so thank you very much for
coming on pleasure thank you there you
go uh Ben Page talking us through some
of the polling figures there interesting
character there to the narrative about
Boris Johnson's popularity and also a
bit of a look forward to those three key
by-elections it could be very
significant indeed
now we are going to be talking to the
chair at the junior doctor's Committee
of BMA ahead of a fresh round of strikes
next week that is Rob laurenson so a
little later on the program as well
we're going to be talking about the
menopause with the labor MP Karen Harris
so two very interesting stories coming
up next but we're also going to be going
live to Ukraine and speaking to our
special correspondent Alex Crawford the
first British broadcaster to the scene
of flooding after the blowing up of a
key Dam in Ukraine really delighted to
have Alex on the program this morning
foreign
[Music]
doctors in the NHS out on strike again
next week starting on Wednesday morning
for three days and their Union the
British Medical Association says the
government's offer is incredible
ministers say demands for up to 35
increases to make up for years of below
inflation pay at supplements is
unaffordable well we're joined out by
the bmes junior Dr committee chair Rob
lawrenson who joins us now thank you
good morning
so strikes next week what's the impact
going to be well I think it's a real
shame that we're having to call strike
action again because the government's
offer which was 5 and 1500 pounds was
nothing to that began to even restore
the pay erosion and in fact would have
led to another real terms pay cut so
unfortunately we've had to call for
another three days of strike action and
I'm afraid that there will be some
disruption in elective and outpatient
care for patients which I don't think
anyone in this country can afford so I
don't understand why the government
won't come back to the table and won't
put a credible offer to the table I want
to talk about what a creditable offer
would look like in a moment but just to
sort of talk in a minute about the
impact on patients you know we're
looking at some of the hospital plans
the strikes and you know you often see
statements like this one from Kings
College Hospital in London you know to
help us safely manage the impact of the
strikes we've taken the decision to
postpone the vast majority of non-urgent
appointments and procedures
in a non-urgent makes it sound not so
bad but you know these people might be
waiting months years even for procedures
would you like to apologize to them well
I think you make a really good point
there in that when you when um Hospital
leaders say non-urgent non-urgent might
be something like non-cancer but it's
still really important to each
individual patient who has been waiting
so would you apologize to them often
waiting for a really long time I think
what's really important is that the
government has failed for over a decade
now to produce a credible Workforce plan
that's going to be able to address
outpatient waiting times and we've seen
over the last 10 years waiting times for
appointments go up and up and up it's
the government's responsibility to fund
and resource a healthcare system that
works for everyone in this country I
think a lot of people would agree with
that including people who aren't being
impacted by these strikes
but why don't you just apologize to the
people who as you say will be impacted
by the strikes next week the strikes
don't have to go ahead though to the
table and the government can give us a
credible offer I will I promise I will
talk to you about a credible payoff over
but would you would you like to
apologize to the people or is that not
something you're happy to do I I can
understand that there's going to be an
immense amount of frustration from
patients and from our other colleagues
when our uh when our doctors go on
strike this weekend and it's going to
cause an immense source of frustration
for everyone
myself my family we all rely on the NHS
as well and the disruption caused is not
pleasant for anyone involved it's a
disaster and it's a disaster that falls
primarily at the feet of government okay
okay understood now what is the current
state of play then when it comes to
talks well the government actually they
obliterated any sense of good faith in
those negotiations when they came out of
an offer of five percent and fifteen
hundred pounds this is an offer that's
been tabled to all public sector pay
work all public sector workers and it
just goes to show that Rishi sunak who's
the man who's leading this decree
doesn't recognize the detail and Nuance
of each individual industry he wants to
treat us all with a blunt instrument of
the same payoffer and it doesn't
recognize the extreme pressures that
doctors are under and the extreme pay
erosion that doctors have suffered over
the last 15 years you say that you know
everyone's got this offer and you make
the argument that actually it's a blunt
instrument that there are specific
things about Junior doctors but I guess
the counter argument would be why are
you different from other people in the
public sector many of them including
people who work the NHS who've accepted
the offer on the table
so doctors have suffered now a 31.7 pay
erosion it's increased because Rishi
sunak failed to deliver on keeping
inflation down over the year 22-23 and
doctors have suffered for so long
because we've been operating on a system
of Good Will working under intense
pressures in the NHS not just during the
pandemic but before and I think it's
really
frankly wrong for this government to
continue offering real terms pay cuts
even during this dispute which is
fundamentally about pay restoration
you've say you call the strike because
the government's failed to make a
credible payoffer I guess the government
would say you've also failed to make a
credible
pay offer as well if you like you know
originally you said you wanted a 35
increase some would say that is just
never going to happen what would you
accept so our paid demand is for full
pay restoration so that no doctor is
worth less now than they were in 2008
because we've sustained 15 years of
paper so what would that mean then in
simple terms what what payers are you
looking for something that reverses our
uh our pay erosion philosophy so what is
that then what is that number is that 35
well it depends depending on how many
years we want to look over it and that's
something that we're interested in
discussing with the government in order
to make the one-off cost look smaller
but I noticed I'm just trying to I'm
just trying to I'm just trying to get to
the simple kind of headline here forgive
me for being slightly Bamboozled by the
figures but but what what is that
roughly I mean are you talking
10 are you talking 35 what would that
look like well it depends how many years
we want to look over okay so how many
years do you want to look over then what
would it be well we're happy to look
over a range of years but we need to be
working with governments to understand
where their headspace is and what they
think is Affordable now I think when
they say fair and reasonable then
they're not being fair and reasonable a
real terms pay cut this year is further
pay erosion
pay rise be fair and reasonable no it
wasn't because more than 10 we would yes
because our pay erosion has been 31.7
now over 15 years so you want more than
30 pay rise we would need to structure
it over a series of years and that's
something that we'd be happy to do but I
noticed in one of your previous
interviews you yourself even describes
one billion pounds as a rounding error
uh yeah this was talking about the very
good attention to detail I was talking
about at labors at 28 billion pounds at
Green investment for example so if you
were looking at a labor government which
we could very well be seeing would you
be happy then if they wouldn't give you
a 35 pay rise but they'd be willing to
spend 28 billion pounds on growing
investment is that what you're saying so
our priorities here are to represent
doctors and to be able to restore the
payrolls that doctors have seen because
as you said at the beginning of our
interview waiting times for appointments
are astronomically high it's not fair or
reasonable for patients to be waiting
two years for outpatient elective
activity and we can only do we can only
fix that issue if we fix the workforce
crisis
um on Thursday you announce your re
balloting members to extend your strike
mandate Beyond August so how long could
these strikes go on for well we'll be
rebalancing between the 19th of June and
31st of August that will give us an
extended six months mandates which will
look towards March of 2024 and if we
need to we will rebalance again during
that period to extend our mandate
further so it could you're talking about
the first
deadline being effectively March next
year but that could be extended if you
don't get what you want you're in this
for the Long Haul our members have given
us a clear instruction they would like
us to pursue full pay restoration back
to 2008 and that's what we intend to do
in our representation of our doctors and
our Healthcare System no matter what the
impact is on the NHS and non-patients
the long-term impact of on the NHS
without a Workforce and without doctors
as they flee to countries like Canada
Australia and New Zealand is that these
waiting lists will increase we heard
from the Royal College of Radiologists
recently that there are significant
delays to Cancer Care all year round not
just in Winter all year round because of
a lack of Workforce okay thank you very
much for being on the program you've
certainly made your points very strongly
this morning thank you
they go uh junior doctors strikes no end
in sights pretty clear from that
interview unless there is a breakthrough
in those talks that frankly that does
look optimistic doesn't it if you look
at the current state of play
now it's five days since we learned uh
that the novo kakova Dam in Ukraine have
been destroyed and a huge amount of
water Unleashed leading to devastating
flooding and environmental damage in
Ukraine and it's a key moment in the war
as Ukrainian forces launch a
counter-offensive to retake occupied
land now Sky News was the first British
broadcaster in the area and our special
correspondent Alex Crawford and team
sent us some extraordinary report she
joins us now at live from Ukraine a real
pleasure to have you on the program Alex
talk us through the kind of thing you've
been witnessing in the last few days
well it's a it's a huge Calamity and the
very first day the day that it happened
we got down there sort of sometime in
the afternoon and the first thing that
struck us was first how much water there
was there and secondly how few people
were actually helping and how most of
the people who were helping were
ukrainians by that stage there had
already been declared an emergency
president zielinski had been up since
the beginning of the morning telling
everyone that it were holding emergency
meetings with his National Security
Council alerting the world uh that
there'd been this huge Calamity the
mayor of the area had been telling
people to get out save yourselves move
quickly because the a critical point was
going to hit within a few hours and
that's exactly what happened over the
next three four days we saw the waters
creep up and up and up so streets that
we were able to Wade through at the
beginning you couldn't get down without
a boat by the following morning and then
the third morning it was it was up
covering the top of street signs and the
tip of of ruse
even three four days on there was still
hardly any sign certainly that we saw
any evidence at all of international Aid
organizations taking part in What was
clearly a huge humanitarian and
ecological disaster it was mainly
volunteers a lot of Ukrainian volunteers
Ukrainian residents who were just
finding their own boats getting dinghies
and and pushing them out to try and save
animals and humans many of whom had
stayed after that first night thinking
because the waters were coming in at a
regular but slowish Pace they'd stayed
overnight and then the following morning
found themselves you know surrounded by
water and unable to get out with no
electricity and things were obviously
going to get worse and worse so the
president zelenski by the third day was
really denouncing what he called the
shameful indifference by a certain
Global World players who really
criticize the aid organizations of
course remember a lot of the aid
organizations are already based in
Ukraine because of the ongoing
humanitarian catastrophe calls caused by
the war
um so there's there's no sudden having
to rush to this country to help out they
were already based here but very very
few seem to be on the ground actually
helping out and then by Thursday it got
even worse because by this stage there
were quite a large collection of
Ukrainian volunteers citizens trying to
help out and and really motor the the
relief operation when the there was a
lot of shelling and attacks right on the
evacuation points more than one
evacuation points which we witnessed
ourselves and this morning we've heard
that the UN has asked for and been
refused permission to get to the the
Left Bank which is under Russian
occupation the other side of the danipro
river so there is an ongoing human
catastrophe and ecocide is how president
zielinski described that this
environmental catastrophe because it's
not just the short-term impact of what's
happening right in front of us with
elderly frail vulnerable people and
children some of whom are fleeing
themselves from the Russian occupied
side and making it over and talking
about how Russian troops are looting
their houses on the Left Bank how they
themselves appear to have been taken
Surprise by the dam burst and how
they're trying to steal their boats to
escape and and how they feel like the
the they're being attacked as they're
leaving not only is that happening but
there's an ongoing long-term impact of
600 square kilometers of just the
hairson region the case on oblast which
is underwater and this water is filthy
it's full of sewage oil toxic
chemicals all sorts of things as well as
floating landmines which have been
dislodged by this torrent of water which
is rushing down and we've seen 160
kilometers away from hereson City in
Odessa sofas and broken washing machines
and even a dog floating on top of a door
Landing up 160 kilometer kilometers
Downstream of the river so a huge
catastrophe here that's unfolding on top
of the war with evacuations being
conducted Under Fire it's extraordinary
just when you feel that things can get
any worse in Ukraine it feels like
something else utterly unimaginable
happens Alex thank you so much for being
on the program and thank you for your
reporting that you've been doing on Sky
News as well from Ukraine Alex Crawford
speaking to us there on the program
now menopause is perhaps a word that we
should be hearing an awful lot more on
uh television as something that we
haven't always been good at talking
about and it does feel that given so
much of the population is going to
experience it it's something that we
could do a bit better about speaking
about now my next guest is an MP who
wants to do more to challenge some of
those uh debates and challenges around
Women's Health give more support to the
13 million women currently going through
stages of the menopause Karen Harris is
with us today it's been a real pleasure
to have you on the show
um you know what it's been such a busy
week in Westminster and I've been really
Keen to do this interview on the
menopause and I don't think I would have
forgiven myself and I thought because if
they're so popular that's going on with
the blokes in Westminster that we didn't
end up conversation so I'm delighted to
have that here
um your chair of your party group on the
menopause why is it important that we
talk about this more well 51 of the
population 13 million menopausal women
in this country and only one one four
fourteen percent of them are getting the
support and the medication they need
we've got to do better that women are
given up work women are walking away
from marriages domestic violence
increases suicide increases by 16
amongst menopausal women and it's all
down to a lack of knowledge and the lack
of services it's so easily remedy Sophie
so you talk about the lack of knowledge
and I think this is quite important
isn't it because you can't get help
unless you know what it is you need to
get help for that you're going through
it do you think people are just missing
the signs of it well I'm a classic
example of that in that I mean I thought
in 2010 I was having a nervous breakdown
I ended up on antidepressants stayed on
them for eight years believing in mental
health problems became an MP was talking
about menopause in the House of Commons
and how we needed to do more for women
didn't acknowledge that I was menopausal
because I didn't link up the the other
symptoms I just looked at the anxiety
and the depression I didn't think about
the restless legs the dry eyes the
migraine the itchy skin the aches and
the pains I just thought that was part
of being a woman and getting older once
I embraced it I went on HRT I'm 20 years
younger that's exactly that's
extraordinary isn't it and do you think
it's because everyone just experiences
it differently
every woman's menopause is different but
there's such a lack of knowledge around
what the menopause is and that is
something that we can work with and we
can look after and we can get women
through it and women are wonderful they
will survive anything we know that but
the menopause is something most
definitely we can survive and thrive
from and it was really interesting
because I was reading some of what
you've written about your own
experiences saying that you didn't
realize that you're in the menopause
um and saying that you were very tired
you're having to push yourself at work
and you said
um I used to love going on holidays
places like Florida even the thought of
going to the local park was too much I
just didn't do it just didn't do it I
mean I came up with so many excuses not
to go on holidays and
I'm away all week when I come home I
want no I don't want to be packing a
case to go on all this any excuse not to
have to venture out of my safe Zone but
I could I knew how far I could push
myself I could walk up the stairs
halfway stop carry on the rest I'm a
completely different person I've been
taking ownership I've owned my menopause
and you say it went on HR HRT why do you
think
people are reluctant to use it because
there was a really bad study that came
out about 25 years ago which said that
HRT could cause breast cancer what they
never told us is that 20 women develop
breast cancer those 20 women actually
had breast cancer in the family so the
chances are they were going to get it
anyway but a lot of the doctors haven't
forgotten that a lot of women haven't
forgotten that so there's a massive
piece of work needs to be done about
re-educating people on the safetiness of
menopause it's also a brilliant HRT
prevents other conditions like
um dementia heart disease there's so
many things that when your hormones go
you are going to get more of and also if
it improves your quality of life that is
I can't tell you the difference it made
to me and every woman I speak to says
that once they take control of it their
life is transformed and now you
published a report at the end of last
year with the recommendations for change
what do you think needs to happen
everything that's in my report whatever
I say that you need to swap my menopause
needs to happen and I will not stop
until we get to the point where we're
not asking for women to have special
treatment we're asking for women to have
the opportunity to be normal they'll be
given the respect and the consideration
in all areas of social policy that
actually acknowledge that menopause is
preventing women from working it's
causing women to be on long-term sick
it's causing women to be an
antidepressants women women women
Women's Health need I say more Sophie no
you don't need to say anymore that that
will do just fine thank you so much for
being on the program this morning it's
been really great to talk to you a very
powerful advocate for uh that cause in
particular
well it's been such a pet show we are
going to go straight into safe Ridge on
Sunday at the take it is a roller
coaster uh Scott has ripped up the
rundown uh in my ear so it's a chance to
look back at our interviews this morning
on the program try and work out what
we've learned and what it means for the
week ahead because it certainly has been
a dramatic few days in Westminster
because of course we've seen uh haven't
we because we've seen the resignation of
Boris Johnson the dramatic resignation
of Boris Johnson and on the program
today of course we heard the world has
moved on according to Grant chaps
I'm hoping we should be hearing from
Grant chaps now
the world has sort of moved on from what
was quite a dramatic period under brexit
and of course under the you know the
issues related to the to covid and the
vaccine and the rest of it so do you
think it was moved on from Boris Johnson
okay I mean just factually speaking
Boris Johnson's no longer prime minister
and you know as I said I think people
appreciate I I like Boris Johnson I
worked under his administration he had
successes many successes to his name in
including breaking the brexit impasse
and including getting this country
vaccinated first but there was also
always a lot of drama that came with all
of that
towards moved on we're here to give us a
take on that and the mornings of their
political interviews I'm delighted to
say we are joined by the political
editor at the southern Sunday that's
Kate Ferguson and the acting Deputy
political editor for the guardian Peter
Walker and I feel like you two people
who I know very well because I see
Rudolph's stuff so much and yet this is
the first time you're on the program so
it's great to have you thank you great
what a week for it as well
um we just heard from Grant chaps I mean
I thought he was pretty brutal when it
came to Boris Johnson what do you think
yeah the thing is with Grant you always
get this kind of affable very
conversational interview don't you and
then scratch beneath the servers and
he's kind of kills boys with a thousand
tiny Cuts doesn't he if the country's
moved on now Boris can go and make money
elsewhere in the world I think you
pointed out earlier so yeah definitely
quite damning and what he does say even
though he delivers it very kindly he
sugars the pill yeah and it's
interesting because he's obviously a
number tens person this morning and so
we can read between the landlines and
say that this is an authorized point of
view from number 10.
I think it is I think rishi's gonna just
really really wants this circus to move
on and you know it's a difficult time
it's going to be a difficult few weeks
the by-election it's going to be tricky
but at the back of their minds they're
going to be thinking this could be it
this kind of traveling circus that comes
into town every few weeks could finally
be over and for number 10 that would
ultimately probably be quite a good
thing yeah it's interesting isn't it
well Grant shops actually I did ask him
How likely a Boris Johnson combat was
let's have a little quick listen to what
he has to say here
do you think Boris Johnson will come
back I have the one thing I know about
Boris Johnson is never predict what
Boris Johnson will will do next I have
no idea uh what will happen uh regards
to that would you like to know I I'm
sure he's got many other things he wants
to get on to do it doesn't sound like
you're really gagging
he spent a huge amount he's spending a
lot of time around the world uh uh
making a lot of uh so that's what you
want to do leave the country it's not
just Parliament I said hey you don't
like you won't find me saying bad things
about brothers I enjoyed working with
Boris I thought he was uh I thought he
was the right man for that time
particularly to break that brexit empath
which he successfully did I thought he
was very good leading in leadership of
the world in Ukraine after the invasion
and other things but a lot of drama came
with it
you won't hear me saying bad things
about Boris Johnson
last 20 minutes
what do you think the chances are of a
Boris Johnson comeback it's so odd
because I began my working week as a
Sunday reporter on Tuesday and I had a
lunch with someone on Wednesday and they
said don't rule out Boris coming back as
a leader people are already succession
planning in case Richie doesn't win the
next election and then you end the week
with Boris Johnson resigning and people
are still talking about whether or not
he could come back as a leader so the
chances of a comeback I mean it's
certainly not yet right because he just
delivered his resignation letter but you
can rule nothing out with Boris can you
and clearly a lot of his supporters are
still sort of talking about it still a
little bit of hope that maybe one day in
the future he is this vote winner that
could come back could deliver yeah he
said for now didn't he in his
resignation statement he's deliberately
leaving the door open there I mean with
the caveat my political predictions are
very often wrong I can't see it
happening I mean the interesting thing
that Ben Page going through the polling
numbers Boris Johnson is not actually
that popular and and there's this big
kind of myth built up about him because
he's a politician he's very very
different he has this kind of
playfulness to him which voters do like
he treats it all he kind of looks into
the camera and says you know between you
and me isn't this all a big joke and
people like that and he delivered a very
different conservative vote in 2019 but
if you look at the actual votes he only
got about 1.2 percentage points more
than Teresa may got in 2017 which is
seen as really really bad he just won
them under the British electoral system
in a way that meant the majority was uh
80 seats so I always think that this
idea that he's this amazing vote win I
mean in as London may he did very very
well that's probably the high point of
his kind of popularity and I think
people have tried him as prime minister
they've seen what he's like and I don't
think people would necessarily want to
go back to the chaos and that's not just
the public but his uh MPS too yeah
they're particularly his MPS as well
it's interesting to say that as well
isn't it I just wonder because I'm
trying to work out where there's leaves
is this really destabilizing because
you've got Boris Johnson writing this
extraordinary diatribe against him
and you've got the by-elections of
course to come or actually will number
10 be thinking thank goodness he's
leaving the Parliamentary stage things
can get back to normal yeah I mean Boris
has been this King across the water on
the back benches not often on the back
benches now kind of doing other things
but that's been his role and I think
number 10 are kind of watching to see
which way this goes on the one hand
you've got these three kind of really
nightmare by-elections mid beds they're
going to throw the kitchen sink at that
but that could go lib Dem Uxbridge
they've already privately sort of
admitting that's going to go labor and
Selby if I think probably more expected
to be a Tory hold but we will get wait
and see but clearly Boris he'll always
be very important a former PM a former
leader but crucially he won't be there
in Parliament might that actually give
Rishi some more breathing space if if if
he gets over these landmines in between
which is these three by-elections here
what's your take
I think it's really interesting to me
what Kate was saying earlier about the
week feeling incredibly long I spent
yeah I spent the start of the week which
is going back on his U.S trip and this
was this kind of very different very
non-boris Johnson incremental trying to
build up kind of policy achievements
here and there so he met Joe Biden they
got on well they signed this uh
agreement which doesn't necessarily
achieve much but it's symbolically quite
interesting and on the plane back he
seemed quite chipper and it's this whole
thing that whenever you talk to
ministers or MPS and they look at what a
Rishi Suna collection win could be it's
just being steady steady steady hoping a
year 18 months time the inflation
figures are better growth is better and
they find this tiny Landing Zone and
every time Boris Johnson pops up it
pushes them of course and they knew I
mean it's not like there was no way this
was going to end in drama at some point
because it could have potentially been
even worse if it had gone to a vote on
whatever the Privileges committee
verdict it was and they have to you know
have dozens of MPS voting for Johnson
and then you have potentially a
by-election all that drama so you could
almost argue this is about as good as it
gets which is still not very good I
guess still not very good but perhaps
the best possible outcome one thing I
was thinking so because then is um but
where Prime Ministers that dare get on a
plane and go away
I think it was in Rwanda and then he
went off to Germany afterwards and he
came back to these by-election losses
right and that was sort of the really
the beginning of the end for him and it
all unraveled pretty quickly after that
so A Russia needs to be careful whenever
he gets on that jet things are in order
back home yeah totally keep an eye on
them don't trust them
um we heard a lot from gonchamps this
morning but we also spoke to go to Hari
who was with Ross Johnson in the city
hall days as mayor but also more
recently his communications director and
we heard a very very different line from
him let's hear from what he has to say
what he's done is take charge this
weekend of a situation that was out of
his control and drifting you know
inevitably towards a very very unhappy
and undignified sort of conclusion and
so if you like he's gone jumping in you
know waving Union Jacks if you like
um rather than be dried kicking and
screaming out of Parliament and though I
won't join those who open exercise the
process and all that I do understand why
he feels uh understandably aggrieved by
the process that has not only taken him
out of office stopped him being prime
minister but now hounded him out of
politics because as you rightly said he
is a man who uh defied political gravity
and only a couple of years or a few
years ago won the biggest majority for
40 years he dramatically quit a seat for
now
today is going to be back uh you never
know he keeps you know he deliberately
leaves us guessing doesn't he hasta la
vista baby or you know more classical
references it's very important it's
virtually impossible to to write him off
but I don't think this is part of an
elaborate plot to sort of destabilize
and topple Rishi sunak I think uh Boris
Johnson feels that there is an
opportunity for him now to go off and
you know lick his wounds but also sees
New Opportunities is very talented uh
person he's in demand around the world
as a speaker he's writing his Memoirs
he's a great writer so there's a little
time for him to be out of The Fray but
will he come back one day who knows the
relationship between rishikina and Boris
Johnson is obviously pretty toxic right
well I sat down with him every morning
you know about 8 15 for seven months of
my life felt like a lot longer and um
and actually I was surprised when I got
there because I had not met uh Rishi
sunak but the personal chemistry was
very very warm the two of them got on
really well that was at one time it's
now changed well yeah but what I'm
saying is I don't think it's a personal
thing I think it's you know Rishi is now
doing the job that Boris used to do now
none of us feel very good about people
doing that if it's been forced upon us
it was quite interesting talking to
critique so we did get a bit more of a
sense about what those allies around
Boris Johnson are feeling he used the
phrase hounded out
um that voters in 2019 could feel quite
aggrieved by what's happened okay I'm
interested in your view on that well
what do you think Sun On Sunday readers
will be on there Sun On Sunday readers
lots of our readers are Boris voters
they know Boris they like Boris also
Boris they've heard of Boris they like
him they think they know who he is what
he stands for now very few politicians
even few Prime Ministers political
leaders can have that kind of reach that
kind of resonance with my readers so
there's this you know we know that
there's a lot of love with it for him
having having said that you know our
readers also do want political stability
they want inflation to come down they
want the votes to stop if you're talking
about rishi's five priorities they chime
actually with our letters Pages our
letters bags every week so it's for
hours I don't think it's always like a
choice between like Boris versus it's
not kind of head-on collision there's a
lot about love for Boris but you know
really now we just want um I think the
economy to improve and that their their
their interests yeah literally and what
I would say about Boris allies in the
Parliamentary party obviously I've been
calling them all weekend and there is
real Fury among the some real Fury at
how he's been treated others also cross
at how he's been treated but it doesn't
necessarily mean they're all going to
follow Nigel in the Nadine out of the
door some of these people are sort of
just starting their political careers
and they're not ready to kind of kiss
them goodbye for the boss no matter how
much love they have for the old boss
that is interesting isn't it you can
kind of get that sense don't you I mean
you've got obviously two of his
staunchest allies who have quit
then if they quit Parliament maybe they
lose influence as well all right so it's
not necessarily a win for Boris I think
it's interesting and I think perhaps the
time people knew the game was up for him
in terms of him coming back was when was
she soon acts Norman protocol got voted
on and there was all these threats of
people who back Johnson when they vote
against it and then Rebellion turned out
to be tiny yeah and I mean to go back to
what some of the things that guitar was
saying this idea that it's a kind of
plot
to take it back out a bit a bit broader
I think this is a slightly worrying
Trend I mean politicians have never
necessarily taken responsibility for
things that have gone wrong
anytime someone leaves office now it
seems to be it's not their fault you
know there's trusts in her first
um uh newspaper opinion piece after she
left was blaming kind of shadowy forces
it wasn't shadowy forces just her MPS
had completely lost confidence and
ability to do the job
and a lot of this stuff ties into these
ideas about you know the blob and kind
of anti-brexit feeling and we're nowhere
near this position we have in the U.S of
conspiracy theories becoming mainstream
but this is what you might call the
house trained end of con conspiracy
theories and I think it's a bit for
worry I think at some points politicians
should say
you know maybe I did actually mess up
it's interesting this idea of The Blob
Jake Berry mentioned it in his tweet
didn't he say it was the blob that
effectively forced Boris Johnson out
it's trying to block brexit I mean the
blob actually started off as the
teachers unions right under Michael go
that was the original blob oh yeah yeah
uh the teachers Union's trying to block
his education reforms but it's now
morphed into a whole well anything
almost yeah I mean I think we talk about
the blob I'm a huge fan of the film The
Blob so you know anyway
viewers do go and watch it but anyway um
but the Blobby happened it's kind of
this catch-all term isn't it for a sort
of refusing establishment so whether or
not that's a kind of civil service that
isn't fully behind real reforms and
going for it gun ho or a kind of
political establishment potentially
elected who were kind of seen to be
fiddling the not the books what's the
word like the the levers of power is
there to get their way look you might
like the phase of the blog you might not
like the place of blog I think the the
thing here is that clearly there is and
among a bunch of Tory MPS that a man
that was feminine practically elected as
PM did Tom storm to Victory with a kind
of thumping majority has now not only
been kind of toppled from number 10 but
also his seat never to a popular
Democratic vote but you know with the
machinations of parliament we've got
something to think about out of time
it's been fascinating to talk uh thank
you very much for watching sofa Ridge on
Sunday this morning we probably are the
blog for most people in Westminster from
The Blob to you have a great weekend